a hundred years ago humanity set forth  to populate the moon  this was our first wave of lunar  colonization greedily we mined the moon  but our world government had to  intervene limiting lunar operations the  moon was abandoned  left alone the year is now 22:05 energy  and resources have become scarce  we at the global union are granting your  new corporation an incredible  opportunity to take a second leap  to reach the stars  we see the promise in your knowledge and  technology extend your reach to new  frontiers  find new resources many obstacles may  block your way we believe you will  prosper let the next rays into space  begin  shape the future of our kind  you can lead the way or us all  you